why are you so good at playing morally
questions later but you're really good
at it I said about you and I think it's
because you don't know what I'm thinking
it's a little scary yeah but that works
in drama that's pretty good right you
know this success has been so great and
I don't know if you heard this is kind
of news but I I qualified for an
entourage like a week ago you qualified
for I got a letter in a mail in the mail
it said I qualified for the entourage I
don't know if it was sag or what Union
it was or maybe it was I didn't know
they assigned you auntie you don't have
to achieve a certain Q rating or so I
don't know what but they're with me
tonight would you like you have an
entourage where are they they're in the
dressing room
could we get any camera let's get a
camera let's get a camera on but yeah
who are they yeah first that's oh that's
Johnny T Jackie daddy see thanks to him
you got Dexter Dexter
d-man yeah knuckles Oh watch out for
knuckles Billy the Shiv and Scott Van
der Horne
[Laughter]
what are they what do they do nothing
comes I don't know what to do yeah
alright I don't know what the acid can I
ask them to do stuff yeah they're not
sure I'm sure I don't have any interests
yeah shared interests you got to figure
it out you got an entourage you know and
I have a question um could I just go off
the other way and just leave them here
can't do that we've have we have a sign
back there no we've had this problem
before people leave them show the sign
you cannot we are not responsible for
entourage
it's just something that we and we have
to enforce that because people just
leave their ice vanilla ice left someone
here actually you vanilla what he was in
his own entourage and talk about
existential it was a very weird so
alright yeah
you